- I don't think of myself as a boss.
I think of myself as someone
who's giving direction.
I think it's healthy for everyone
to lose a job as well as to gain a job.
I like people who represent the best
of what they do and if that turns you
into a perfectionist, then maybe I am.
I think the more you go
out, the more you see,
the more you experience life,
the more you bring back to your day job.
- She's a British journalist and editor.
She's been Editor in
Chief of Vogue since 1988.
She's Anna Wintour,
and here is my take on her
Top 10 Rules For Success.
Rule number five is my personal favorite,
and I'm curious to figure out which one
you guys like the best.
- I try and be decisive.
I try even if I don't know
what the hell I'm doing,
I try to be decisive because I think
it's very comforting and reassuring
and important to the
people that work with you
to feel that whoever is in charge knows
what they're doing and
knows what they're thinking.
That if it's a yes, it's a yes,
and if it's a no, it's a no.
I mean I don't think of myself as a boss.
I think of myself as someone
who's giving direction,
guidance, and vice-a-versa.
And, I also know careerwise how important
it is not to be too highly specialized.
Especially these days
in the world of media.
It is crucial to have multiple
interests and skill sets.
To have tried and possibly failed
at many different undertakings.
The young people that we
hire today at Conde Nast,
are fearless polymaths.
Hardworking and passionate,
creative and curious.
- You eventually joined
Harper's Bazaar U.S.
And in 1976 it was, you were fired,
and I find that extraordinary.
- (chuckles) No, they were
very clear in that they thought
that I would never understand
the American market.
I remember, I was the editor
on one shoot that was,
I think it was the French fashion shows,
and I decided that it would be interesting
to have dreadlocks on the models.
I think that that pushed them
further than they could bear.
That was it for me.
But I think it's always part of life
to have some knocks as
well as some successes.
- And to take risks.
- And you know, to learn.
So I think it's healthy for everyone
to lose a job as well as to gain a job.
- [Interviewer] What bores you?
- Mediocrity.
If you see a collection that is,
you feel the designer has been lazy
or taking inspiration
from other designers.
It doesn't so much as bore me as anger me.
- What is your best piece of advice
for the next generation's influencers?
- I think it's really
to be true to yourself,
and listen as much as one is able
to other people who's opinions you respect
and look up to, but in the end
it has to come from you
and you can't really worry too much
by looking to the left
or the right about what
the competition might be doing,
or other people in your
field might be doing.
It has to be a true vision.
- The blurb about your
unauthorized biography reads,
"She's ambitious, driven,
needy, a perfectionist.
"An inside look at the competitive
"bitch-eat-bitch world of fashion."
Accurate?
- Well I'm very driven by what I do.
I am certainly very competitive.
What else am I needy?
I'm probably very needy, yes.
A bitch?
- Perfectionist.
- Oh that's right, bitch first.
(laughing)
- Well, I hope I'm not.
I try not to be,
but I like people who represent
the best of what they do.
If that turns you into
perfectionist, then maybe I am.
I don't ...
make notes.
I react very instinctively to everything.
I'm a great believer in
traveling a great deal.
I don't believe in meetings.
More than two people in
a meeting is too many.
(laughing) Really it's true.
Do you know about stand ups?
No, okay.
So in Silicon Valley now
when you have a meeting
everybody stands in a circle
like they're meditating.
(audience laughing)
Maybe I should try that.
I think the more you go
out, the more you see,
the more you experience life,
the more you bring back to your day job.
As I was trying to say in my remarks,
I think the problem about big corporations
is you get a lot of people my age
trying to hold onto their jobs.
Clinging onto their pensions
and their retirement,
and they're not experiencing new things,
and they don't like change and
they don't like disruption.
So either they don't make a decision
or they say no and as
a result they stagnate.
It's terribly important to bring
people in from the outside,
and not to remain too insular.
And also to hire as many
young, bright people,
like all of you, as you
can just to teach you
how to think about things
completely differently.
Well, I think all of us at Vogue
are always looking for talent.
And we're also looking for someone
who has a head on their
shoulders and that understand
that being talented is
obviously important,
but that you also have to
have a sense of business.
And that being creative and commercial
are two words that can work together.
It's very important to me that I look good
when I go out publicly.
I like looking at my
clothes rack in the morning
and deciding what to pick out.
I enjoy fashion.
I mean, I wouldn't be
in this job if I didn't.
I think clarity is one of the most
important leadership
qualities that one can have.
I think it's really
important to be very specific
and very clear on what you
expect, and then to delegate.
People respond much better when
they're in a more independent environment
and you're not completely breathing down
their neck all the time.
The other thing I think
is incredibly important is
to hire divas like Andre Leon Talley.
Who will disagree with
you and contradict you
and not yes you all the time.
And not to be scared of
having people working
with you that have different opinions.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Mauri Sylvester asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Anna's top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
Leave it in the comments and
I will join in the discussion.
Finally, want to give a shout
out to Jesse Willoughby.
Jesse thank you so much for
buying the copy of my book.
It really means a lot to me.
For your chance at a shout
out in a future video,
make sure to pick up a copy of the book,
and email in your receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe or
whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you soon.